[Music]
like me
to catch
me
I thought you were gonna catch it you
better back up this is incredible how
you feeling
um yeah like you know a sense of
achievement I guess this show has been
five years in the making and we've shot
it over a year and a half it's it was a
lot and then I see it come together and
this amazing experience and be here with
the entire cast it's
it's really special really special I
feel like are you getting emotional I
did a little bit it was a tough time it
was 2021 it was during covid you know we
were all away from our families it was a
tough show I I saw Nick walking by
looking Dapper of course he got the memo
too he got the memo actually are kind of
pointing a little bit
um has he seen the show yet yes he's
seen multiple versions of it
um but sweetly he's gonna watch it again
I don't think he's seen it on the big
screen though he must be like
kind of I mean red dress and all I mean
come on come on what are three words you
would use to describe this series
um dynamic
[Music]
um
complex and propulsive
pulsive yes just keeps moving uh what I
mean when I think about buying like my
thesaurus and my brain I love it I love
it when I think about the russos I think
the globalness how they're building
towards something they're doing kind of
this this Global thing are you involved
with the other shows that they're
working on at this point well the only
thing I can say is that the storytelling
and the stories of all the shows will be
connected so how involved involved the
actors will be I don't know you'll have
to watch but the stories are all
connected I know you guys have been
having so much fun in London did you get
in on any of the music video action no
I've been doing press sitting in that
cave with you talking to me I'm so sorry
forget to do anything nothing
yeah no we've had a couple of walks uh
you know we went to the Transport Museum
that was cute with the baby that was
nice that's amazing yeah thank you so
much thank you so good to see you good
to see you again
foreign
[Music]